so I have been hearing about this
project for many many years and you know
you guys are finally there and you're
seeing it when you're with George and
other scientists and I guess my question
is did it seem more or less feasible
more or less plausible more or less
achievable and and what kind of
resources are going to be required
that's a perfect question because I was
sort of going there looking for that and
part of it is the sheer competence of
those Imams both of them and the the
depth of time and commitment that
they've made there that they've got the
beginnings about real-life demo of you
know what had been an essay on science
magazine some while back when you have a
density of animals on the land it really
starts to change in the way that one
would be glad of and there's all these
more animals so basically the land
coming back to life but that sheer
confidence they have I mean they're in
such an impossible situation all day
every day from our standpoint that the
fact that they can somehow I mean Nikita
has stories to tell of you know getting
through the snow and almost dying and
being in the situation where he's lost
he's not treats going in the right
direction he's frozen oh they all have
stories like this
and so these are insanely competent
characters and I trust their science and
I trust their capability to carry it
through and a completely different level
in the lab I feel the same way about
George church so this particular project
is in such good hands and the science I
think is so well proven at this point
that I believe it will all go forward so
I think it for me was it was both sides
of this equation we're both I was
stunned to find out how realistic it was
to do that kind of the basic science of
this project and I was also stunned at
how massive the scale of the problem is
and how immediate that tundra melting
problem is it was literally the summer
that we were there that and
the week we were there the pub the paper
was published around the frozen layer
not huge portions of it not freezing and
you you know after you fly 10 hours
across Siberia you're like wow there's
there's a lot of stuff to do here
so look out if all that lambs get you in
flying over for 10 hours and think all
of this landscape is becoming a
greenhouse gas problem and might be
converted over time and do a greenhouse
gas solution that's big and doesn't even
include northern North America yet but
it will
I don't have much doubt that a mammoth
will be resurrected and that even could
have the effect of clearing Pleistocene
Park I think it's another level of
belief to imagine it you know spreading
across all Siberia I mean it could but
that's that's just another question so I
think I think there's different levels
of success and I think I think that
success the the close success of making
a version of a mammoth and having it
have an effect within that area I think
that looks like it's kinda couldn't
really happen whether it takes off or
whether it has the total effect
everybody wants I think that's much much
more uncertain but if I think the first
thing seems very plausible to me Jason
and David what if you see yeah I mean
you know you're asking a couple of
Millennials if we can edit genes and I
think you know that's that's natural
right let me just grew up in the era of
seeing computers change rapidly and so
this feels very national part of like
our timeline and witnessing technology I
mean I think for us as filmmakers you
know I think the thing that word that we
know that our audience is going to be
asking is that sort of Jurassic Park
question right you spend so much
I'm thinking if you could do it you
didn't stop Thank You chef laying the
table well to us there's like so much
more interesting ideas there should we
and what does it mean when humans both
decide to do it to go forward with that
or if you decide not to choose to select
not to use technology to try to
safeguard the planet I think there's
just so much there at that just there's
not clear answers but it should be
talked about
[Music]